hi Megan
I thought that I have been clear about
the number of buttons that can be
unbuttoned are you body shaming her
right now Jeremy come on
it's winter can we put dancer and
prancer back and they're stable if I
gave you like your stripper girlfriend
put my children on her motorcycle one
more time I will gone girl you so hard
I'm just going okay so are you gonna be
inviting your fake girlfriend to the
holiday party later I mean there's one
make sure you have time to inflator this
party has to rock did you rent a live
baby what it's cheaper than you think
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Savannah oh my gosh you guys are gonna
have so much fun tonight I'm not even
gonna County because we're friends right
yeah we're not oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
you do not want to die at the hands of
Lululemon here be real embarrassing for
you you're a large guy and she's made a
nothing but salad and smart water
[Applause]
[Music]
somebody know it's my sister
you're having a Christmas party tonight
so it's not a Christmas party it's a
nondenominational holiday mixer more
inclusive well whatever you call it it's
not happening all right it's canceled
hey idiot I'm looking right at you okay
we're not doing it we'll still do it
this branch is failing I'm shutting you
down you got to give us a little bit of
time to turn this around all right if by
some miracle you can close Walter Davis
and his 14 million dollar account their
jobs are safe John you'll see you're
gonna look so stupid then we'll finally
have something in common guys would if
we fill him with the greatest time of
his life at our Christmas party tonight
this always need a raise job it's not
the worst idea Walter do you party I
used to
if F word Christmas be words let's get
mother F word drunk flop it it's my
birthday
oh really committing like the candle
greatest party ever
hashtag open bar what are you sending
that to everyone in Chicago
I'm CEOs you know check please just
drive I just talked all four people
there at that party tonight hey Amy
three stars like a bunch of [ __ ] what
did you just say I said there were a
bunch of [ __ ]
tonight the decisions you make will have
consequences that will haunt you for the
rest of your professional life pull over
or I will shoot your penis in the face
[Music]
I think he meant to swing there where'd
you get these be better if I didn't say
oh pardon me
[Music]
it's Christmas we should celebrate they
said
[Music]
just a little get-together for the
employees have a few drinks blow off a
little steam nothing crazy
Merry Christmas Jeremy great night huh
this is a sample cheese Forge for a
holiday mixer tonight I'm sorry you're
having a Christmas party tonight it's
not happening all right it's cancelled
hey idiot I'm looking right at you I'm
telling you the thing is not happening
at all I'm not messing with you hey stop
doing that all right
it's you are going to have intercourse
tonight please do not do a nun company
property building to the right a parking
lot we're talking right it ain't baby
make it all night Oh
what a party I think he meant to swing
there all right so I've made a list of
my first round of layoffs say you won't
make budget cuts here comes a loogie
it's brass everybody's gonna get a bonus
why didn't do this yourself
they know I took down your subscriber
God Carol you know he's turning blue
yeah our family you got a tab there she
is my sister from another mister I'm
kidding
our mother didn't start having affairs
until the mid 90s what are you doing
here well we were just going over your
fourth-quarter earnings and I wondered
if I was missing something probably so
we were all a little bit disappointed
not to have 7% growth in this last
quarter but 6.5 percent is right on
industry standards oh you need to hit 12
percent 12 12 is the new seven since
when since dad died and the board made
me CEO you mean interim CEO shut up hmm
I am sorry I hate tension at night I've
heard it Wow is there anything else
actually yes this is a sample cheese
board for a holiday mixer tonight I'm
sorry you're having a Christmas party
tonight it's not happening
all right it's canceled hey idiot I'm
looking right at you I'm telling you the
thing is not happening at all I'm not
messing with you hey stop doing it
Oh sweetie that is so great
mommy's so proud of you hey could you
put your daddy back on the phone for a
second they also need you ready you
[ __ ] [ __ ] if I hear you let
your stripper girlfriend put my children
on her motorcycle one more time
that will gone girl you so hard I'm just
gonna go in Thank You Walter Davis yeah
where is he I don't know where was he he
was just on the stage
now I want to do something that scatters
to feel like all those lines buddy
[Applause]
I think he meant to swing there no you
can leave the Santa suit in the Attic
why because I'm an adult I don't you
know dressing up as Santa Claus would be
embarrassing Hey unless you know you're
doing it for charity then it's then it's
um sorry tell Dad that I love oh lucky
he'll be down for five bucks okay hang
it up mom okay ready okay you look
ridiculous
is it the Hat
party people in a place to be the issue
that they Steve
crazy
Oh
Merry Christmas Cena Chuck it's me Santa
Claus I'm gonna come into town for an
epic night ah ah okay we'll get there
did you eat my Cinnabon no what's your
name sweetie
Darcy mm-hmm hi Santa
yes Carol Vanstone I'm here with Darcy I
know
terrible name and she's being a little
[ __ ] here in the first-class lounge so I
think we should cancel all of her
Christmas presents this year
great bye I hope it was worth it
you